fashion has evolved over the years and
who knows what will be fashionable
tomorrow but one thing everyone knows is
that there have certainly been some
questionable trends in the past if you
are a first-time viewer click the red
subscribe button and enjoy
try not to cringe as we discuss
outrageous fashion trends you won't
believe where one's popular bullet bras
we aren't sure why or how the bullet bra
came into existence it looks more like a
torture device than a bra the whole
purpose of a bra is to lift and separate
but for some reason the bullet bra
inventors wanted their undergarment to
look like it could double as a weapon
either way by the time the eighties
rolled around women gave up on their
cone-shaped bras and embraced a more
round approach foot binding there is a
saying that talks about suffering for
fashion but in ancient China they
brought it to a whole other meaning rich
women in China practice the tradition of
foot binding shrinking their feet which
broke bones and caused loss of
circulation in extreme cases women would
get gangrene and their toes would fall
off or they would die thankfully the
tradition is now illegal and women in
China can finally accept their adult
human sized feet whale tails
thanks to Britney Spears and other
popular celebs the I'm aware or whale
tale fashion trend came into existence
in the late 90s early 2000s the trends
led fashionable ladies to wear thongs
that cared about their low-cut jeans
thus creating what looked like a whale's
tail this was every parent's worst
nightmare and after a few years the
trend died down the rat tails who could
forget the one haircut even trashy er
than the mullet the rat tail in the 80s
everyone from the new kids on the block
to fashion models rocked the ridiculous
trend for those who are lucky enough to
not know what a rat tail is it's a long
tail like piece of hair growing from the
back of the head sounds sexy right
backwards jeans the 90s were responsible
for many questionable trends but one of
the most infamous was the backwards
jeans trend the innovative trend became
popular thanks to young hip hop group
criss cross the boys wanted to come up
with their own style of dressing and
didn't think of anything better than
wearing their jeans backwards
thus confusing every parent of trim
teenagers who insisted on wearing their
pants the wrong way around
grunge grunge was a 90s fashion movement
that was anti fashion which makes total
sense it screamed I haven't washed my
hair in days and I found this shirt on
the floor in still it read the trend
derailed the fashion industry forever
and there are still traces of the trend
in every pair of holey jeans you see the
good news is people have started to wash
their clothes again and thankfully their
hair armadillo shoes in 2010 fashion
label Alexander McQueen launched their
ridiculous high heels called armadillo
shoes there were only 21 armadillo shoes
in existence but Lady Gaga
snatched a pair up to wear in her bad
romance music video the lobster claw
looking shoe had a price tag of 4
thousand to ten thousand dollars and
were impossible to walk in the whole
trend was a wait for the fashion label
to help people escape reality but there
is no reality where women can walk in
impossibly high heels that they spent
$10,000 on flared pants
the rise of flared pants or bell-bottoms
started in the late 60s hippies wore
them with tie-dye shirts and love beads
we aren't sure why hippies needed extra
ankle space but considering they were
avid LSD fans it's understandable
people aren't expected to make great
fashion decisions when they aren't even
sure what world they're in this is
another trend that has made a few
comebacks like the bootleg jeans trend
in the early 2000s but thankfully flare
pants haven't made a hundred percent
return grills gold plated teeth are
nothing new but it's pretty crazy that's
something that fix your decaying teeth
for once considered a status symbol the
trend started in Miami in the late 60s
and became mainstream in the 80s though
grills were a staple for hip hop artists
they have been able to crossover to
mainstream fashion icons as well these
days people like Madonna and Cara
Delevingne randomly rock versions of the
detachable gold teeth accessories
mullets in the 80s the most notorious
hairstyle was the mullet the iconic
business in the front party in the back
haircut took on many forms and some of
our favorite stars adopted the look
everyone from David Bowie to Blake
Shelton rocked a glorious mullet
it was a tough look to pull off
considering its popularity which
ultimately led to its demise in the
early 90s
sagging pants out of all the fashion
trends on this list and none angered
older generations more than sagging
pants the look consisted of guys wearing
their pants so loud that it showed their
underwear and looked like the pants may
fall off some people even had the
audacity to wear belts and still have
sagging pants
it seems fashion was so appalled by the
trend that they developed jeggings in
hopes they would be impossible to sag
shel suits the 80s were full of awful
trends and one of the biggest was the
shell suit also known as track suits
it wasn't like everyone suddenly took up
running but that didn't stop them from
looking the part the polyester pants and
jacket combo were lightweight and just
sporty enough to convince people you
worked out though the suit provided no
shape the shell suit has tried to come
back over the years disguising itself as
a track jacket but all in all it is
stayed in the 80s where it belongs
leaving tags on not everyone can afford
luxury fashion because of that teens in
the early 90s came up with a solution
instead of showing off fancy designer
logos team showed off price tags leaving
price tags on clothing was a status
symbol and the trend even infiltrated
nursery schools grandparents would try
to rip tags off their pre-k age
children's clothing only to be met with
protests for doing so as the teenagers
and toddlers got older they realized how
silly the trend was and eventually grew
out of it harem pants if Disney movies
are to be believed harem pants have been
around for thousands of years just look
at Aladdin rocking the trend but years
before Disney's movie Aladdin hit the
silver screen a rapper MC Hammer made
harem pants famous again the drop crotch
pants were quite comfortable but they
looked ridiculous they've had a more
recent modern update in 2015 but they
still haven't conquered making people
not look stupid for wearing them stilt
walkers the 19th century French
countryside is home to one of the most
bizarre trends in history chango's or
big legs was a trend that was functional
and fashionable at the same time for
anyone who doesn't know jenga's was a
trend in land France where shepherds
attach stilts to their legs to help them
get through the marshy terrain but
shepherds weren't the only ones who
wanted to look like Giants villagers
women and children even became added
stilt walkers which probably made for
the creepiest 19th century village for
someone to stump
upon by the early 20th century the LAN
stilt-walkers were more of a novelty as
they performed for circuses around
Europe thus ending their freakshow
Village trend are you surprised by any
of these outrageous fashion trends react
in the comments section below and don't
forget to subscribe to the things for
more awesome videos